they're fundamental questions that are
arising all the time like how do I
distribute my work and energy and effort
every minute of the day you have to face
such question sometimes there I wouldn't
exactly call it an ethical dilemma but
although I guess it is I mean so for
example in the early 60s I had to make a
really hard for me a hard decision
should I start becoming really active
instead of just talking in a critical
human issues that were arising then the
war in Vietnam the growing war in
Vietnam the civil rights movement many
others so should I become really active
in those where should I devote my time
and energy to very exciting intellectual
work into my growing family I had little
children well that's a hard decision I
knew perfectly well that you can't just
put your foot in it and walk away if you
get started it's a growing commitment
and my wife and I had to work that out
and some fashion was not simple in fact
at one point she actually had to go back
to college after 17 years because it
looked as though it might serve a long
prison sentence we had three kids to
take care of
well there's decisions that's a serious
decision but there are lots of others
you